uh so okay going to the afc though
who would you say is the biggest
challenger
to the chiefs buffalo team
yeah buffalo that hurt
that hurts because you know i've been
rolling with the steelers all year
but the who you know the who oh stop the
who oh don't don't act like that
oh don't act like no don't act like oh
no i'm not no no no that's not that's
not about you that's about me
no that's about look i'm hiding look i
i'm i'm
i'm trying to like you know give me hold
on let me
get this right this this this is how i
should be talking about the steelers
today
just like this i should just be i should
i i shouldn't even show my face
why i mean look no i mean because they
shut they shut me up
not that they were listening but you
know well
i mean well no a lot of times
a lot's happened since we last talked
and i mean
listen the colts are that first half i
was right
but that second half against the colts
they fell they found themselves
they found themselves you know um
i didn't think they had so i so i did
promise
i did promise a steelers fan that i
would give props when we came back
and obviously you know they they didn't
they didn't bother with week 17 so much
but
you know they handle a business and
they're not 11 and 5 going in like i
thought they would be
okay they won they won a division and
and now they
they turn around and play cleveland this
weekend but but this is why
this is why uh buffalo i think it's an
interesting matchup
buffalo has been putting it on people oh
that game yesterday let's not let's not
just gloss that over
miami really needed to win i mean they
were fighting for their playoff lives
a divisional opponent meaning they
should have known what buffalo was going
to do and buffalo should have known what
miami was going to do
i mean that's just in the end of the
year that should have been a competitive
game
to put 56 points on miami in that
situation
is impressive and the week before
another divisional opponent and i like
the way they said it i think it was dion
dawkins who said about the patriots look
look this is not we're done with this
little little brother stuff
he said don't call us a little brother
anymore we're down being a little
brother
we're done being bullied and they put it
on the patriots too
by the way you always do a little
brothers take it from a little brother
no matter what happens
you'll still be a little brother um but
they
they are a problem diggs is great
josh allen playing like an mvp and
here's here's the underrated part sean
mcdermott
spent almost a decade it may have been a
decade
on andy reid's staff so he knows
he knows i know that when andy reid was
in philly i know
there was no patrick mahomes it was a
completely different dynamic he didn't
have anybody like my homes didn't have
anybody like
uh like tyreek hill or or travis kelsey
i know
but he knows the psyche of andy reid
i think he's going to match up coaching
wise
out of all the coaches in the playoffs i
think sean mcdermott probably has the
best chance
of putting a formulating a game matching
which that could slow them down
well it's not about slowing them down so
can we can we can we put up the uh
the field one more time i know i was uh
i was i
i pulled it off a second ago but can we
put up the afc playoff here one more
time because
so tennessee is
more explosive than one would think
given that their identity is derek henry
but tannehill is you know he he doesn't
take a backseat to
to many at this point obviously
baltimore i told you they'd be there at
the end well
close to it they're in the playoffs
they're on the winning streak they have
the reigning mvp
but they're a running team as well
they're running football team
indianapolis balanced complete
their physical team okay they still got
philip rivers but they're a running team
as well
and cleveland is best when they run the
football we know pittsburgh
can't or doesn't but pittsburgh's
pittsburgh they got a quarterback that's
been there done that
but this is my point about buffalo why i
agree with you
and maybe if i work up the guts assuming
that they see each other
in the afc championship game maybe i'll
work up the guts to actually pick the
upset
but michael i don't know at this point i
don't think it's about slowing down
kansas city i think it's about keeping
up with kansas city
yeah you're right and that's what and
that's what buffalo can do buffalo's the
one team
in this field that could that could go
blow for blow
with the kansas city chiefs and
can engage in a shootout and maybe be
the last team standing
in a shootout against the most dynamic
quarterback
you know in football right now i mean
buffalo
they could put up some points because
the thing about kansas city is they're
never out of it
or they explode and you just can't you
can't catch up
let alone keep up you got to put up
points to beat them now i think i think
you oh you made it around a game if
you're like oh we're going to try to
contain them we're going to possess the
ball
keep my homes on ain't that ain't how
that's going to work
like you know what you're going to have
to outscore them and buffalo's capable
of doing this
if i were in houston working for the
houston chronicle
or the athletic somebody i would do a
whole piece
well-reported piece mike on what has
happened to the houston texas since
what's happened to the texans since they
were up 24-0
i like that happened
in 2020 in 2020
they were up on the on the kansas city
chiefs niners were up ten
the niners were by twenty-four but at
least their organization hasn't fallen
apart but
like since houston was up 24-0 on kansas
city like bill o'brien lost his head
coaching job and general manager
they've they the organizations fall
apart it's falling apart
deshawn watson talking about we need a
culture shift
they were in a divisional playoff up by
24 points on kansas city
that leader evaporated and their
identity their whole organization
collapsed after that you're right
everything can go away quickly when
you're dealing with the kansas city
chiefs and the
and the texans are the best illustration
of it but i mean
i'd say let me revise let me tweak what
i'm saying about kansas city
when i say sean mcdermott can slow them
down
i'm not talking about 23 to 20.
i'm not even talking about 30 to 27 i'm
saying instead of it being
55 to 52 you might be able to beat them
45 to 42.
slow them down where you can come up
with a stop
a stop at a critical time because you're
just not going to
you can't this the evidence is
overwhelming
let's just stop pretending that somebody
can come up with the scheme
that patrick mahomes hasn't seen or he's
going to be confused by
and oh okay it's not it's not just to
stop
i'm i'm with you it's going to take a
complete effort to knock them off a
total team effort as they like to say
all three phases of the game
complementary football
any cliche you want to throw out there
but
phillip rivers baker mayfield
ryan tannehill respectfully ben
roethlisberger
and even lamar jackson who's not been up
to the challenge
patrick mahomes just
whatever advantage you may have
elsewhere he just offsets it
you know josh allen is the one dude in
this field
that could go toe-to-toe with him the
one dude in this field that can
close that gap that the chiefs have at
quarterback
they have a decided advantage at
quarterback they have an equalizer they
got a guy that just makes everything
else
a moot point obsolete josh allen the way
he's playing right now
he can uh he can match patrick mahomes
and you know why do you know what
matters if you look at it and i'm gonna
give your guy a compliment
you got aaron rodgers my guy um
yeah he is your guy i'm about to be
three-time mvp
i mean 48 touchdowns this year let the
league in where completion percentage
passer rating as you said just just
checking you said
it's a quarterback well stop stop with
this whole you know three mvp we should
stop counting mvps
we should stop calling mvp how many
times did you win like best quarterback
the best quarterback award uh was it
eleven out of the last 12
the quarterback does that apply to
brady's mvps or is that just for rogers
and vps i'm just curious
just that's a good question uh honestly
i'll answer that later but you know
aaron rodgers
is really good at you know unscripted
unscripted he he goes from great to
greater
he might even be the greatest unscripted
he
and and patrick mahomes are tied there
play breaks down
now you're really in trouble because you
defended something that you thought was
going to happen
now you got a freestyler out there and
he's going to burn you do
freestyling too but josh allen
watched josh allen when the play breaks
down
when his first year when the play broke
down he broke down
he'd do something stupid now
josh allen on the run is deadly
hey thanks for watching brother from
another on youtube make sure you hit
subscribe before you leave and be sure
to watch us
3 to 5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you